hundreds of protesters flooded the
streets of portland last night at one
point
they chanted feds go home at agents
accused of provoking more violence with
their tactics
at a house judiciary committee hearing
yesterday attorney general william barr
defended the administration's hard line
response
to demonstrators nancy cordes has our
story
i'm going to answer the damn question
attorney general william barr
and republican lawmakers repeatedly
clashed with democrats in an explosive
five-hour hearing i want
the attorney general to be able to have
enough time to respond to accusations
and questions
ask him and you guys not cut him off
what you want is irrelevant
but irrelevant of the rules barr
defended the decision to send federal
agents
to portland and other u.s cities violent
rioters and anarchists
have hijacked legitimate protests
to wreak senseless havoc democrats
questioned his motives
now you are projecting fear and violence
nationwide
in pursuit of obvious political
objectives
shame on you mr barr we are on the
defense it's we're not out
looking for for trouble
demonstrators and local leaders
including portland's mayor argue
protests were winding down before
president trump
sent in federal agents democratic
congresswoman pramila jayapal
accused the administration of a double
standard citing the lack of a response
to anti-lockdown protests in michigan
earlier this year
you take an aggressive approach to black
lives matter protests
but not to right-wing extremists
threatening to lynch a governor
if it's for the trumps if it's for the
president's benefit
barr also defended his decision to
aggressively disperse
peaceful protesters near the white house
last month
well first it's my understanding that no
tear gas was used
but a national guard officer who was on
the ground that day says
that's not true he says he felt the
chemical irritants in his eyes and later
found spent tear gas canisters
trica nancy thank you